depuis hier soir un célèbre footballeur
fait la une des médias Achraf Hakimi
et si l'international marocain est star
du PSG est au cœur de l'actualité ce
n'est pas pour ses exploits sportifs
mais pour de lourdes accusations dont il
fait l'objet
[Musique]
par une enquête pour viol après avoir
échangé avec une jeune femme de 24 ans
sur Instagram Ashraf Hakimi lui aurait
donné rendez-vous chez lui samedi soir à
Boulogne-Billancourt mais dès le
lendemain elle s'est rendu au
commissariat attirant avoir été abusé
par le footballeur le parquet a décidé
d'ouvrir une enquête alors que s'est-il
passé accusation de viol contre le
joueur star du PSG Achraf Hakimi toutes
les dernières informations ce soir dans
TPMP
[Musique]
merci Solange d'être avec nous Solange
moi le journaliste alors Solange
qu'est-ce qu'on s'est de l'histoire il
s'est passé il se serait passé quoi
samedi soir au domicile dash Raphaël bon
écoutez déjà remettre le contexte c'est
un fait divers donc on n'a pas
énormément d'informations si ce n'est ce
qui est sorti dans la presse
mais il y a des on peut avoir des
suppositions on va parler un peu aux
conditionnel parce qu'on va pas non plus
pour noter les spectateurs et pour nous
qui on va revenir sur les faits donc ce
weekend samedi samedi soir elle avait du
Clasico
mpgami qui ne jouait pas parce que la
petite blessure la Coupe du Monde a reçu
aurait reçu à son domicile une jeune
femme de 24 ans qui est issue de
Nogent-sur-Marne donc de 94 donc ça
c'est les infos qu'on a eu et en fait il
flirterait ensemble depuis janvier par
Instagram donc une petite relation
épistolaire si on si on peut dire ça et
il aurait fait venir en taxi chez lui et
c'est là que ça aurait dérapé donc elle
a elle a ce soir là appeler une amie
après sa soirée avec avec le latéral
droit du PSG en lui disant qu'elle avait
brusquée etc par le joueur il aurait
forcé à l'embrasser il aurait pénétrer
avec ses doigts donc d'où la
qualification du viol mais ce qui est un
petit peu surprenant et déroutant de
cette affaire c'est qu'elle n'a pas
porté plainte en fait elle a juste posé
une main courante donc ce qu'il faut
savoir là-bas voilà c'est une grosse
différence parce que quand on peut on
met une main courante la personne qui
est accusée n'est pas forcément au
courant qu'on a voilà qu'on a été le
dénoncé entre guillemets et c'est des
donc c'est sorti alors que il aurait pas
dû le savoir parce que c'est une star la
notoriété tu l'as grave
exactement même si la jeune femme n'a
pas porté plainte le parquet vu
potentiellement la gravité des faits
c'est saisi de l'affaire c'est le
parquet de Créteil dans le Val-de-Marne
ou la jeune femme est allée qui a
transmis à Nanterre parce que le joueur
habite dans le 92 il habite Boulogne
voilà alors il était seul chez lui sa
femme et ses enfants sont en vacances et
il faut dire aussi qu'aujourd'hui via
les médias espagnols un grand quotidien
espagnol sportif qui s'appelle Marca son
entourage a démenti bien sûr il a dit
qu'il était extrêmement serein vous
l'avez signalé Cyril il était hier soir
à la remise du trophée des savoir il
fait partie de l'équipe type et
aujourd'hui son entourage dit achrafaqi
est extrêmement serein il ni qu'il y est
déjà sortie il était très souriant
devant les photocoles etc donc lui de
son côté il semble pas plus bousculer
que ça par cette affaire après moi je me
pose des questions après j'ai pas
forcément le droit de donner mon avis
mais cette jeune femme qui a qui a mis
cette main courante jusqu'à présent on
la trouve pas on Instagram on la trouve
pas non plus c'est vraiment très
difficile de savoir qui qui est cette
jeune femme alors peut-être qu'elle a
été dépassée aussi par les événements
puisque à la base elle était pas partie
porter plainte donc c'est vraiment une
affaire à suivre de très près ensuite il
faut pas oublier que achram Ashraf
Hakimi depuis la Coupe du Monde c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment sur le devant
de la scène avec l'exploit qu'ils ont
fait avec en Coupe du monde avec le
Maroc et il est extrêmement sollicité
par par tout le monde par les médias par
les fans par les femmes c'est vrai de
plus en plus d'histoires comme ça aussi
on sait plus qu'est-ce qui est vrai
qu'est-ce qu'il faut c'est très
compliqué les joueurs qui sont
extrêmement sollicités il faut le dire
il y a des communications qui se font
des des DM privé notamment sur sur
Instagram il y a eu d'autres joueurs qui
ont été mélé à de tels affaires il y a
eu l'affaire Neymar par exemple voilà il
en dit qui a été Cristiano Ronaldo plein
de joueurs donc après c'est très
difficile de démêler le vrai du faux que
s'est-il vraiment passé la jeune femme
pour le moment on n'a pas été entendu
une nouvelle fois par les enquêteurs
mais elle va l'être elle dit qu'elle a
envoyé un SMS à une de ses amis qui est
venue la chercher donc les enquêteurs
vont vérifier la téléphonie savoir ce
qui s'est passé et après on risque
d'être dans un parole contre parole
c'est ce qui peut se passer